قال الناطق الرسمي باسم القوات المسلحه
السودانيه العميد نبيل عبد الله ان القوات
المسلحه وقيادتها ملتزمه بما تم التوافق
عليه في الاتفاق الايطالي واضاف في بيان
مصور ان مزايده البعض على مواقف القوات
المسلحه والحديث عن عدم رغبه قيادتها في
اكمال مسيره التغيير والتحول الديمقراطي
لن تنطلي على شعب على حد قوله
تؤكد قواتكم المسلحه وقيادتها
التزامها التام بمجرات العمليه السياسيه
الجاريه
والتقيد الصارم والتام بما تم التوافق
عليه في الاتفاق الايطالي الذي يفضي الى
توحيد المنظومه العسكريه
وقيام حكومه بقياده مدنيه فيما تبقى من
المرحله الانتقاليه لحين قيام الانتخابات
بنهايتها ان مزايده البعض بمواقف قواتنا
المسلحه وهي اول من بادر بالخروج من
العمليه السياسيه
والحديث عن عدم رغبه قيادتها في اكمال
مسيره التغيير والتحول الديمقراطي
في محاولات مكشوفه للتكسب السياسي
والاستعطاف
وعرقلت مسيره الانتقال
لن تطلع على فتنه الشعب